[Music]
hey drew it's sam i'm a halloween
lifestyle vlogger known online as
halloween happy i'm in my apartment here
in salem massachusetts and i am so
thrilled to show you around i love salem
so much because there's a lot of history
there's always something to do and see
and it has a halloween vibe all year
round which clearly you can tell i'm
obsessed with so grab your broom and
hang on tight and let me show you around
my hometown of salem massachusetts
we are at modern millie which is one of
my favorite shops i love coming here
because they're so nice and they always
make me feel so comfortable in my skin
when i'm trying new things with my style
i see that they have a few halloween
outfits so let's go check it out this is
tiffany
hello hi thank you so much for inviting
us in tell us a little bit about the
shop
we are an inclusive women-owned shop in
downtown salem we sell reproduction
vintage inspired clothing from sizes
extra small right on up to 6x and we're
happy to help style anybody when they
come in
thank you so much for showing us around
modern amelia all right guys on to the
next spot let's go
here we are at the halloween museum and
i love coming here because they
celebrate autumn and salem all year
round the best thing about the halloween
museum is it's in 3d so drew that means
intensified spookiness and with dominic
here at the halloween museum thank you
so much for having us here thanks for
coming welcome to the halloween museum
i'm so excited what can you tell us
about this spooky place
this hallway museum is incredibly
popular the whole month of october here
in salem
a great way to experience halloween and
sailing all year round no matter when
you come and visit
all right drew so i'm a crafter at heart
which leads me to our last stop here in
salem and that is the witchery so let's
go inside and talk with the owner gret
so what do you offer here so the
witchery is a creative space and we
offer book binding workshops and we
offer brewmaking workshop and behind
here you can see some of the brooms that
we make
we let people choose their own materials
to create a custom room
so if you do visit salem definitely
check out the witchery that way you can
make a craft take it home with you and
it's like you're taking a little piece
of salem along with you
well drew that's just a snapshot of my
hometown of salem massachusetts i hope
you love it as much as i do i can't wait
for you to visit and i'll see you soon
bye
[Music]